kevin powers uh asks anybody have good
recommendations for a story planning app
not scripting but a good tool to put
story pieces together
first of all when they said screenwriter
support i thought you were going to be
giving me the support i didn't know it
was the other way around
i've actually never heard of a story
planning app that
might be showing my age hi this is aaron
sorkin
and this is screenwriter support
[Music]
all right holly jack uh people who write
stuff
how do you approach second drafts blank
page and start again
amendments to what you've already got
any thoughts tips would be appreciated
yeah great second drafts are really
important friend of mine once uh said
about me that
uh i don't write scripts i rewrite
scripts and here's what he meant
in the process of writing the first
draft by the time you get to the end
you've sort of discovered what the movie
is about
uh because it may not end up that first
draft being about
what you thought it was going to be
about when you started writing it you
plotted a course to go do north
but as you were going you started going
a little bit
east and then a little bit more east and
and
when you end up you're you're going
northeast so you've figured out
uh what the script is about it's
probably fat it's probably
long go back to the beginning of the
script start writing it
over again peel away the things that
don't have anything to do with your
story hang a lantern on the things that
you need to bring into relief
uh in the story you're gonna discover
that
a problem that you have in the third act
isn't really in the third act it's
because you didn't set it up properly in
the first
so second drafts i say
re-type the whole thing sharpen up that
joke that's kind of clunky sharpen up
that's
that dialogue that's kind of clunky get
it down to its fighting weight
that's what i do anyway thanks a lot for
the question quentin
uh says what's key focusing on creating
the plot
story world character or etc
uh uh when writing a script here's
what's key
uh in in creating drama intention
and obstacle that's what you've got to
cling to
somebody wants something something
standing in their way of getting it
they want the money they want the girl
they want to get to philadelphia they
want to win the big game
they want to save someone's life if
somebody wants something something
formidable is standing in the way of
getting it the tactics that your
protagonist
uses to try to overcome that obstacle or
those series
of obstacles that is
what's going to create your character
because you're not going to tell us who
this character is you're going to show
us
what this character wants it doesn't
matter
if they succeed or fail uh in their
quest
it matters to you it doesn't matter to
story telling it's just a good story if
they fail as if they succeed
um uh what matters is that the intention
be important to them and that we
understand why it's important to them
and the obstacles have to be real
attention and obstacle
thanks a lot quinn caitlin greenridge
says if you are writing a marginalized
character whose identity you do not
share
can you imagine your way into that
character through their joy and not
their imagined
trauma yes uh uh you can
empathy uh right same blood that goes
through
your body goes through that person we
all have as
humans the power to empathize with each
other
uh to understand each other's lives and
to put
any character we want into a dramatic
situation because the most
important thing in your story is it
going to be someone's sexual orientation
their skin color their religion whether
they are able-bodied
or disabled the most important thing is
in your story
is going to be intention and obstacle
what does this character
want and what's standing in their way of
getting it and i assume that because
you're interested in telling this story
you are interested in what the character
wants and what's standing in their way
of getting it
or you think it's a great comic premise
with which you can use your sense of
humor
or you think it's a great premise with
wish to tell a murder mystery
or a romantic comedy or anything like
that
but i really think it's important that
writers not start to get cautious
because they're scared of of being
offensive stereotypes should be avoided
whether it's as you say someone from a
diverse population or someone who looks
exactly like you
um you want to avoid all kinds of
stereotypes
not just because of uh racial or ethnic
uh sensitivity stereotypes are just bad
in
uh in writing i can be different in
every possible way
but if that person is a father i'm a
father
if that person is also a father i feel
like i
know everything about them that's
important to know that you can know
uh as a stranger i can empathize with
that person
you don't want to judge that person
you want to defend that person you want
to be able to make that person's case to
god why they should be allowed into
heaven
do not do not do not feel
that you are required to write about
yourself
and your world write about any world you
want you're making the world uh sorry i
don't mean to be
yelling you i'm just i'm passionate
about this uh okay
you ma'am are not confined by any guard
rails
thank you for your question caitlyn
okay so matthew ward says if you could
write an episode for one tv show
which one would you choose i'm very
curious i'm glad you asked
uh matthew because it's a it's a more
complicated question than you might
think
one of my all-time favorite uh tv shows
the office i like the bbc office too uh
but i am a super fan
of the american office the nbc office so
you would think i would want to write an
episode of that
right except i think i'd do badly i i
think i'd make the office
less good so uh so it would be
self-defeating
if i could go back in time i think i'd
like to write an episode of mash
i was late to catch up to shit's creek
and just started watching it
i totally get all the hype it's
fantastic
that's another show i would love to
write for those actors
but would not do the actors or the show
any favors by
doing so so i would love to go back
to an episode of television i've written
and write it all over again thanks a lot
i appreciate the question
lisa dubois uh real question
are tv writing rooms just rp sessions
i'm not sure what in our oh role-playing
sessions
are different writers in charge of
different characters on show
shows like some kind of sex in the city
d d
okay that's a great question i i don't
think that happens on any show but
uh uh the reason i'm not sure what the
answer is is because
the way most other writers rooms work is
that
at the beginning of the season several
months before production starts
the writers uh meet every day and they
try to break a whole season
arc whether it's 22 on network tv or 13
on uh premium cable that we want to
start here and end here
so if we're going to end here that means
by christmas we need to be here so by
thanksgiving we need to be here
then they get more granular okay so we
need to do this by episode one this by
episode two
and they'll simply assign you take
episode one episode two episode three
episode four
i want you to turn in uh story pitches
in five days and a week after that it's
gonna go to outline and a week after
that it's gonna go to first draft and
then the show runner ultimately runs it
through there
the writers rooms are the four shows
that i've done that's
sports night the west wing studio 60 and
uh the newsroom work entirely
differently than
than writers rooms on other shows
because i'm writing
different episodes while i'm writing an
episode
i have a leader in the room the person
running the room i can come in and say
what do you guys are thinking about and
they'll say
what if josh is subpoenaed to appear in
front of a committee
and this happens that kind of thing
we'll start
banging out that story so they're just
trying to break stories it was an
ordinary day when
all of a sudden what makes this night
different from all other nights that's
how stories and uh and drama go that's
how
our writers room works my shows were run
like
not a well-oiled machine thanks a lot
for your question
riyadh have you been inspired or
influenced by the quality of writing of
particular tv shows and or movies
for me my writing was greatly influenced
by breaking bad you say
and northern exposure two great shows to
be influenced by
big fans of both and the answer is yes
i've been influenced uh by the writing
of a lot of movies and tv shows i'm kind
of an accidental screenwriter i'm i'm a
playwright
who fakes his way through movies and
television shows
by adding sort of just enough visual
stuff uh so that you don't realize what
you're really watching as a play
and so i've been influenced by all the
great playwrights
whose plays i've read or sometimes been
like enough to see
i've been influenced by a lot of uh tv
shows
pretty much any good television show
today i think a show that you would
consider
good is following in the footprints that
larry gelbart
left when he created the tv series mash
he was the first one to say that sitcoms
don't have to be sitcoms you know they
don't have to be
silly you know just because they're
funny they can tell
real stories and uh and moving stories
so i would say that i was
heavily influenced by uh larry gelbart
to be sure
so thanks a lot for your question jd may
asks what are your best tips for writing
villain characters
okay that's a great question and my best
tip is that
you jd cannot think of them as a villain
you can't judge the character you the
writer you can't judge the character
you have to be able to empathize with
that character
find something about that character
that is like you too and then you have
to write that character
like they're making their case to god
why they should be allowed into heaven
i don't know if you've ever seen the
first movie i wrote was based on the
first play that i wrote a few good men
and you probably know you can't handle
the truth uh
that whole you can't handle the truth
scene from nicholson
in the courtroom that is nicholson's
character making his case to god
he should be allowed into heaven even
though
he has committed manslaughter okay even
though he's responsible for the death of
a marine
private he's defending it why it was
actually a good thing
uh to do so whether it's mark zuckerberg
the founder of facebook or nicholson and
a few good men
or anybody else the audience could think
of them as a villain but not you
the real gavin jt asks what do you need
to be successful
if there was a real answer to that uh
everyone would be successful right okay
so
um you need talent there are some things
about writing that can be taught
and learned and there are some things
about writing that that can't be
and those things that can't be that's
usually what we mean
uh uh when we talk about talent uh
whether it's
writing or playing the violin there's
stuff that can be taught and there's
stuff that can't be you need practice
in that regard it's also like playing
the violin you need to
do it a lot and and keep doing it be a
diagnostician
uh when you see a movie you don't like
or an episode of television you don't
like
don't be like your friends who don't
necessarily want to be writers who are
just saying oh god that
that sucked man and they're just making
jokes about everything go ahead and make
jokes and it's okay does it say that
suck but
then when everyone leaves uh and you're
going to sleep try to think about
what was wrong same thing when you love
something
okay so when you're done with the
experiential thing
think about what was so good about that
scene what was so good about that moment
was a little pushing that the camera did
was the way that the joke
uh was set up was it the fact that there
it wasn't scored at all it was
completely dry
or was the whole scene saved by uh uh by
score i know
when i'm talking about score it doesn't
sound like writing things but it is
so that
a little bit of luck thanks a lot for
the question these were great questions
thanks a lot and let us know what you
thought